let's say we wanted to figure out what 3
minus
negative seven thirds
minus 11 thirds is pause this video and
see if you can have a go at it before we
do it together
all right now let's work on this
together
and you might be tempted to deal with
the negative seven thirds and the eleven
thirds first because they already have a
common denominator but you have to
realize that subtraction you can't use
the associative property it's not this
this for example which is what you would
typically do first is not the same thing
as this right over here so you have to
be very very very careful but what we
could do is rewrite this instead of
saying sub minus something minus
something else we could rewrite it in
terms of addition what do I mean by that
well if I have 3 7 I'll start with that
subtracting something is the same thing
as adding that something's opposite so
subtracting negative seven thirds is the
same thing as adding the opposite of
negative seven thirds which is just
positive seven thirds and subtracting 11
thirds is the same thing as adding the
opposite of eleven thirds which is
negative eleven thirds now addition you
can use the associative property you
could do you could add these two first
or you could add these two first and I
like adding these two first because they
have the same denominator
so if I have seven thirds plus negative
11 thirds what is that going to get me
well we have a common denominator we
could rewrite it like this 3 7 plus
common denominator of three we could
write seven plus negative 11 in the
numerator and so 7 plus negative 11 is
the same thing as 7 minus 11 because
subtracting something's the same thing
as adding its opposite so for adding
negative 11 the same thing as
subtracting 11 so 7 plus negative 11 you
might we could get a number line out but
hopefully you've gotten some practice
now that is going to be negative four
that is negative 4. and so now we have 3
7 plus negative four over three and so
now we definitely need to find a common
denominator so let me rewrite this this
is equal to 3 7. Plus
let me write this plus negative four
actually yeah this is fine plus negative
4 over 3 or I could write this as even
negative four thirds either way but if
we want to have a common denominator it
looks like 21 is going to be the least
common multiple of
seven and three so let's rewrite each of
these as something over 21 3 over 7 to
go from 7 to 21 you multiply by three so
three times three is nine and then to go
from 3 to 21 we multiply by seven so if
we have negative 4 times 7 that is
negative twenty-eight and so this is
going to be equal to 9 plus
negative 28 over 21 which is this is the
same thing as 9 minus 28 over 21 because
subtracting a number is the same thing
as adding its opposite and so this gets
us let's see if 9 minus 9 is 0 and then
we're going to have 19 more to go below
zero so this is negative 19 over 21 or
we could write that as negative 19 over
21 and we are done